all men have nipples
and mammary glands and most have the
desire to bond with their babies and
give their partners a breastfeeding
break
alas you cannot milk a man who knew
dad nipples are merely decorative
they're like tinsel on the christmas
tree not very functional but they're
there nonetheless but that doesn't mean
men are technically unable to lactate in
fact the scientific evidence suggests
that it could happen under the right
conditions if you read down in the
article it goes on to tell you that
those right conditions usually mean
there's a there's a medical problem
going on
okay
so men come into this world with all the
right hardware for the job but puberty
sets dads to be down the wrong path for
milk production what do you say
when a man does lactate and yes it
happens this the article explains it is
almost always a symptom of an underlying
medical problem
or thanks to injections of estrogen and
prolactin which come with a slew of side
effects
male lactation is a known side effect of
animal anabolic steroids and thorazine
some antipsychotic medication pituitary
tumors and cirrhosis of the liver can
also make men produce milk from their
nipples so let's bottom line this one
for everyone men don't lactate unless
it's a problem because men aren't women
men aren't women
let's be controversial for a month can
you believe this is controversial in
2022. me saying men aren't women is
controversial
what in heaven's name is going on in
society
so here let's break down men aren't
women
men who identify as women aren't women
men are men
women are women
now if you take a bunch of medication as
the article said maybe you could do
something to your body that's weird
but it's not recommended because there
are side effects that's not what's
supposed to be happening right now
a couple of comments on this
i've said before her i would have loved
to be able to delegate some of the
breastfeeding responsibilities to my
husband i've said it breastfeeding is
hard
okay it's hard it's really hard but it's
very empowering right you're feeding can
you imagine i was able to feed a person
off of my own body
that's some superpower stuff right there
i don't want it taken away from me i
don't want it called chest feeding
i breastfed with my breasts i'm proud to
have done it
stop trying to take that away from women
we're not interested in that game
we know what we did it kept us up at
night it hurts sometimes it's exhausting
but it's very fulfilling and it's very
rewarding and it's very empowering
i wish i would have done it longer
frankly
i did it for
you know true story i did it for four
months almost four months because i had
to go back to work and i was working
very challenging jobs some of you know i
was working the fox and friends weekend
shift i was up at three in the morning
and there were these long stretches of
time when i couldn't pump milk and weird
stuff would happen like leakage it was a
lot going on so i had to stop if i could
go back i would go back and i would
prioritize that breastfeeding i would
place my job as number two because now i
know a lot of the benefits that i didn't
know then about breastfeeding regardless
we'll get back to this because there's
some more stuff that we have to talk
about when it comes to baby formula and
the fda
we'll get there
but can i just say on this article with
why can't breastfeed
why does this column need to exist
we are now in a time where this is the
great debate
all right let's sit down
and let's really talk about first world
problems too
food shortages people can't find their
baby formula you can't put gas in your
car and everyone's like no no
let's talk about whether men can
breastfeed i think it's an important
debate
is it though
anyway they felt the need to weigh in
because doesn't everybody
this is a this is this is a sign of the
sickness that we're in right that this
is what we're talking about
it's pretty obvious guys girls whoever
however you identify it's pretty obvious
that men can't breastfeed and there is a
biological reason why okay can we just
why is that not sufficient to just end
that topic and move on
they even they even have a saying for it
maybe it's a southern thing but the old
saying is uh it's about as worthless as
tits on a boar here you go
that's okay i've never heard that never
yeah maybe it's a southerner did you
have have you ever had the desire tyler
to breastfeed a bit do you sit and say i
wish that was something i could do
truthfully i wonder how men feel about
this sometimes nope no not at once it's
hard it's very hard and let me tell you
something now that i know the benefits
of it
man i would have been breastfeeding that
child until a year old i would have had
milk stocked up to the ceiling i was i
was not i knew it was good i knew it was
healthy but i didn't realize how much i
was giving off by not going for a full
year i'll tell you that have you seen uh
have you seen grownups adam sandler and
kevin james
no but i feel like a scene is popping
into my head it's she's breastfeeding
her child and they ask her they go how's
your child in 48 months yeah that's four
yeah is it no
really late actually um what's her name
the woman who used to be on blossom
ma'am i can always forget her name wrong
and i say it wrong all the time she
breastfed really late and people get a
lot of heat for that i had a friend who
breastfed for a really long time and at
the time i was like what are you doing
now i'm like biolic
she breastfed for a really long time
it's good it's really good for the
babies
it's really good i'm very grateful i did
it i'm very angry at myself
for for stopping to prioritize some job
um and that's another thing by the way
side note people who love who say they
have no regrets in life they're lying
everybody's got some regret everybody's
got something they would do differently
don't say you don't don't say oh no not
my life
it's full of no regrets no you're lying
there's something in there if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here